foreign
let's do a lightning round cue the uh
pervy hip thrusting music
you don't like that
no it that's the music that Kelly Gets
Dressed to every morning and it's just
uncomfortable
he tells us sometimes she calls when
she's brushing her teeth and that music
is just blaring in the background she
wants to talk about a show segment or
something it's super awkward so on brand
for her all right lightning round let's
do it yes all right we're doing
lightning round anxiety and depression
it's gonna be so fun
Zoe
I just imagine you telling your husband
like we are going to clean the house
it's gonna be so fun yes we're gonna
have the we're gonna smile while we do
it we're gonna clean the roof off it's
gonna be great so far yeah okay go ahead
go for it first question you often hear
of people being diagnosed with anxiety
and depression together why are the two
so often connected so when something's
diagnosed together it's called comorbid
um I guess that means you
die again maybe that's what that means
not really not comorbid um but it
anxiety and depression are on the same
trend line and so you and I may have
different genetics and different life
experiences that lead us to this moment
and a bear runs in that door and your
body shuts off and it's going to stay
shut off for a while and my body's gonna
get up and spin up and get ready to rock
and roll often the difference between
the two is not the particular stressor
it's just how our bodies are responding
and in in some brain scans studies it
shows that the very similar brain
mechanisms are are driving both of those
all I have to say is
um they're on the same trend line and if
you're anxious long enough long enough
long enough your body will shut the
system down and um and sometimes it
works vice versa I'll have to say is
that's why perfect is that helpful yeah
I was going to say thank you for
bringing up my deathly fear of bears so
you have that oh yeah
I've had nightmares they just chase me
I'm not going to see cocaine bear let me
just say that all right next next
question we're moving on what is the
difference between a panic attack and an
anxiety attack
um
not a lot
um panic I think that's again I think
that's kind of Internet splitting panic
attacks usually don't have a trigger
they just show up so we'll be walking on
the street and all of a sudden I'll get
real short of breath my heart will be
there thousand miles an hour and I'll
double over and I don't I my brain
starts I start spinning with all these
negative thoughts anxiety attack is
usually I got a test I got a test I got
a test I got a test and it slowly wears
you down the reason I don't care so much
about which one it is is the
physiological mechanisms are usually
pretty similar
your body your heart starts beating
really fast your body is ready to go to
war right or it's ready to get the heck
out of there and so
um yeah it's one of those things that if
you're sitting there and someone you
love can't breathe and they're
hyperventilating and they're having all
these catastrophic thoughts and you're
trying to figure out well is this a
panic attack or an anxiety it's not
helpful not helpful right right
um okay so are there any symptoms of an
anxiety attack that I can pinpoint
before it happens
sure anxiety attack I mean just using
the internet literature which is those
that wasn't very good
there's not never mind
um my science friends will just roll
their eyes at what I just said and um so
save your question again I'm sorry I got
lost
I don't have a lot of friends
are there any symptoms of an anxiety
attack I can pinpoint before it happens
uh I mean if you if if you start
ruminating pretty hard and you start
spitting yourself up and the thoughts
you are having beginned your heart
starts racing on you and
um
you start having real shallows of breath
and you will feel like I need to go for
a walk but I can't go for a walk that's
you feel it starting to come on
um and again that's so human that's so
person specific right so it's I I don't
want someone being like I think I'm
having a panic attack I think I'm having
anxiety attack because you can sure talk
your way into one right
um I think getting Upstream as soon as
you start having those ruminating
thoughts that's when you can build in
some I'm gonna stop this conversation
right now or I've talked about on the
show I'll be walking through my living
room and I'll just be like no stop or
I'll be in the shower and my wife will
hear me yell out no and that's just me
I'm stopping a conversation a fight that
I'm having because I don't want to end
up down down river that way right
um does alcohol or caffeine cause
anxiety
oh that's a great question
um I tend to think caffeine mimics
the symptomology of I mean symptoms of
anxiety and so uh if I have way way way
too much caffeine I start my brain
starts spinning a little faster my heart
rate is beating my I'm kind of clinched
up a little bit and then my body's like
oh we're supposed to be anxious right
now and it will it will follow suit
um alcohol has some Gaba effects I don't
get all that stuff but yes there's a
reason why
um I think on a limke says it talks
about it best about the teeter-totter
and if you depress
neurochemicals on one side your brain
will respond by Smashing the other side
of the teeter-totter and so if you have
a depressant effect and you shut some of
the system down it will come back in
full force on the other side so yes it
can there's a reason why you wake up in
the morning after you've had too many
drinks the night before and you have
that anxious feeling what I say what did
I say do they think I was crazy
who did I kiss like all that I mean
that's a natural I don't get all the the
Neuroscience of it but yes
awesome and I also think this I also
think in the long term alcohol has uh
it messes with sleep and it screws up
your REM sleep and over time a body
deprived of REM sleep will begin to try
to get your attention and let you know
things are not well at home and it'll
start rattling so I think there's a
long-term effect there too yeah what are
the best things to do when having an
anxiety attack drink just kidding don't
do that
um the the so this happened in a parking
lot I pulled up and there was a bunch of
people leaning into a car and I was like
what is happening over there and
um I walked over and realized it's the
somebody yelled someone's having an
anxiety attacks I was having a panic
attack and so I cleared everybody out of
the way and then I reached in and said
will you take my hand and she did and I
said would you be willing to walk with
me so she got out of the car and I
literally put her hand on my chest and
we went for a walk and so I held skin to
skin contact here I let her feel my
heartbeat literally and we walked around
the parking lot and I had her look at
things like tell me what's there she's
like there's grass I'm like yes where's
the leaves and she's like there's one
there's one and all I was trying to do
was bring her body into the right now
and um so skin to skin contact heartbeat
like
um just getting your body from some
future Terror to you're here right now
and you're okay and it's pretty quick
yeah I've I've kind of dealt with that
before where I find it helpful to do
like the 54321 method where it's like
five things that I can see just to kind
of like get my mind off four things that
I can hear three things I can feel two
things I can smell I've never heard that
one thing I can taste kind of like to
get your senses to like start focusing
on something else and by the end of it
my breathing's calm down my heart rate's
down and I just find it so helpful I
like that
um back when I was doing death
notifications or I I would show up to
somebody's house and there was Madness
um we used to just go for walks and it
was not be strange for me to be holding
hands with a 55 year old man walking
down the street
and all we're doing is just counting
cracks in the sidewalk like let's count
one two and let's count the trees and so
we're just coming back to humanity here
because what he just saw
um his life will never be the same yeah
right yeah
um next question you say anxiety is like
a smoke alarm can you explain that uh
yeah in our culture we've turned anxiety
into a disease or into a genetic
disorder or into some sort of illness
that um comes upon you like the flu or
like coverage like you something you
catch and so when people say the words
like I have anxiety it's either talking
like it's an identity like this is who I
am now I'm just an anxious person who
experiences the world in this way or I
have a thing that I caught I've got a
thing now and um I reject both of those
across I mean all that across the board
all anxiety is is your body trying to
get your attention it's just trying to
let you know generally speaking you
haven't been taking care of your body
um like me too much caffeine 300 400
milligrams of caffeine a day my body's
gonna start rattling after a while
um and then I'm not sleeping and then so
on and so forth I'm disconnected your
body's found itself without a tribe and
by the way you can be have great work
mates you can be married and happy and
you can be profoundly and deeply alone
and so it is
um when your body detects you don't have
a tribe that you are all alone or if
you're not safe if you're in an abusive
relationship you don't have autonomy you
don't get to make decisions for your
life the bank does your your boss does
things like that
awesome okay next one here's why that's
important if you feel anxious if you
rush to stop the anxiousness
man that
that's like getting shot and rushing to
just cover up the hole in your body
instead of trying to figure out where is
bullets coming from right who's shooting
and why and so
when you feel anxious man what a gift
your body to step back at least an inch
and just say what are you trying to
protect me from if we all just asked
ourselves that question man we'd have a
radically different world right yeah
um my husband's anxiety can lead to him
lashing out at me how can I help him at
these times I I reject that sentiment
um nobody's anything makes him do
anything or very very rarely
your husband is choosing to respond to
those alarms by swinging and so what you
can do is you can't make him do or do
anything you can control you and so if
your husband gets anxious and then
lashes out you can say I will not be in
a home where I feel unsafe so when you
get anxious and you lash out I am taking
that behavior as as a language and the
language you are giving me is I don't
want you here anymore and so I will
leave I will not be in a place where
someone's going to talk to me that way
treat me like that way and if you have
anxiety and your body's impulse is to
lash out right fight or flight I'm gonna
fight
um when I get anxious my body's response
is to run and that's not helpful when I
have two little kids and I have a wife
at home and I've got work and all that
kind of stuff so when you find that your
body has an Impulse when it gets anxious
it's my responsibility
to deal with anxiety to deal with that
impulse and to continue to treat people
with dignity and respect including
myself that's on me I have to
do the things that I know I need to do
to get well sometimes let's go sit with
a counselor sometimes let's go talk to a
medical doctor psychiatrist whatever
that looks like that's my responsibility
not
um somebody else's yep that's good
um is there such a thing as situational
anxiety like before a job interview
going out of town some have flying
I mean we're getting into semantics here
I just call that stress and yes there's
tons of stress and stress is really good
for you this morning
um I was lifting weights and if I had
lifted weights with no weight on the bar
that would not have done my body any
good so I put weight on the bar so it
would stress my body out so that my body
can respond to that stress in an
appropriate way similarly like if you've
got a job interview I want your body
needs to have some stress man it's a big
deal don't screw this up you're not
gonna get that job right you need to
prepare you need to shower
um I don't know I was gonna say bathe
bathe and shower whatever you need to do
um get some sit down with some people
and go over your interview answers
whatever so stress can push us to do
good things
um so that that's a situational anxiety
I mean I mean
I just call that stress
awesome okay last question is anxiety
ever beneficial
yes
um good grief Almighty who wrote the
what's there's a book called good
anxiety
um who wrote that
I can't believe I just lost Yeah Wendy
Suzuki yeah good grief I can't believe I
lost her name
um
she I mean she really maintains what I
just said that when your alarm systems
are going off they're actually that's a
good thing I would say my uh smoke alarm
in my house is a good thing she would
say when your body's trying to get your
attention and you go exercise then it's
done good for you and so you can reframe
it
um I also
I mean anxiety is such a catch-all word
nowadays for anything that makes us go
we all say I got anxiety not really when
I had clinical anxiety there was nothing
good about it it burned a hole through
me um and it burned a hole through my
relationships and I did not respond well
to it so actually it didn't burn whole
through my relationships I did and so
there wasn't a lot good with it
um in retrospect as I began to get well
I begin to see that I'd created a world
that wasn't inhabitable for me or for my
family and so I guess it was good in
that way but man I wish my body had done
it another way but to be honest it it
probably was trying to get my attention
for a long time and
it just hadn't been able to do it so it
finally started shutting the thing down
well that was I don't know I mean you've
experienced it have you ever felt it to
be good
um
oh I don't
I don't maybe in some situations where
I'm like oh my gosh if I wasn't feeling
anxiety I'm like maybe there's something
wrong with me that I'm not feeling
anxious about this thing
um like you said like for job interviews
like the stress like before of like if
I'm not feeling anxious and like excited
and ready
there's something wrong with me gotcha
so I think that's the only way that I
could see it as beneficial in my mind
but gotcha
yeah I I don't know
here's what I don't like about the
internet culture we're in now is there's
going to be someone who's got anxiety
who's doubled over with it and I don't
want their husband being like it's good
for you and that's terrible and on the
other side I don't want somebody who's
stressed out about something
who thinks they've and this is the world
we got where people have just regular
stress life is stressful life's hard and
everyone runs to
do away with the discomfort and they
label it some sort of Diagnostic and or
they now we've got what was that one we
had the other day that was uh
high functioning anxiety it was just
making up crap now like
like when you start labeling everything
with a diagnostic and to try to do away
with any sort of discomfort and you do
with away with any sort of growth in the
world any way of getting from point A to
point B and we just want to stay in
atrophy and I I I don't know so I I
don't like the question just because
it's it can be weaponized either way and
I think stress is usually good until
there's too much of it or it becomes a
way of life and I think anxiety can get
your attention in a positive way and it
can also bury you so
um I don't say it's good or bad I think
it just is I think how we respond to it
is really what determines whether it's
good or bad
awesome well I had fun that's over
you're so ridiculous well I had a great
time great time all right cool that's it
that was uh are you gonna take us out
with some more jamming Tunes I mean I
can
I think the world needs some more of
this